[Music]
now get ready for slime time actually is
that something you can really get ready
for I don't know but apparently John
Cena can't get it up with the green
stuff because he is back as host of the
Nickelodeon Kids Choice Awards about the
slime you just have to get over it
it is going to happen that's what you
expect when you try to avoid it it's not
good
[Applause]
and right in the slime zone the front
row will sit John's Beyonce Nikki
Bella's he's gonna sound so corny but I
know my bride-to-be is gonna be here
I'll get to walk the carpet with her
tomorrow we'll be able to enjoy the show
together and we'll be able to have a
little bit of a date afterwards they
actually had a date sort of today on
Ellen when Nikki surprised John with the
prom haven't seen Nicole in quite a
while and I turn around and she's there
and she looks beautiful this look of
just pure love that we could only hope
for he's just so awesome and so very
thoughtful it hasn't been all rosy since
John's very public proposal last year
rumors of a split surfaced after this
tease for the upcoming season of total
Bellas so we really want to call this
off and you did go through a rough spot
but the wedding is on and Lord and
you're good I love her I don't want to
live without her and the fact that you
said you hadn't seen her in so long
that's why you kept smooching her more I
could all right look don't forget the
Kids Choice Awards air tomorrow night on
Nickelodeon live from the world-famous
forum in Inglewood California
[Music]